[music]
if I can say
Honestly it
feels like it's all one day and so on the
sixth day or the seventh day of the war from
that day I feel like it's all one
long day I don't see much
difference 5 months of war or 6
months is different  only when
we feel that on the battlefield we
stabilize the situation or vice versa. We
are lucky that we are somewhere in some directions.
to be able to see each other
and thanks to you By the way thank you for the interview
this is one of those abilities to see And
it is very important sometimes You know We are all
alive People we must be strong But we are
all alive People sometimes you
are not uh very close  you see a person somewhere
nearby to talk to and you miss it
so much, you miss your children and your wife. I think
that you probably can't get used to this and you
can turn to everything else.
Thank you for this, those in the idea and really we
get every day every time for
such interviews.  with pleasure or separately
because we can see because indeed
all these months Volodymyr lives at work,
we are with the children separately and I can
see him several times a week here
in the office and the children very rarely can
see him, so they really miss their dad  and
such a serious period in the life of our
daughter, who has finished school and is now
entering the exam in two days,
and she is preparing for it very carefully,
and we need a date to talk
with him so that this period of entering
adulthood will pass more easily. Unfortunately,
we cannot afford it now  to allow it And
what supports it is that you understand that you are
not the only one And in general, all Ukrainians
now live in such situations, all are
separated, all are waiting for our victory
in order to
unite again And live a normal
human life, which we always wanted to live
I can only add that I completely
agree with green. It seems to me that it is definitely much more difficult for people
who are in the
occupied territories,
and we cannot turn to such things,
and we must do everything so that Deo
buys these territories, at least
preserve them, at least preserve these people,
do not lose their hope
Breaking
I can first look. And I have always
been a supporter of the theory that trials
only strengthen strong families. I am sure
that with us I think that the same thing will happen with us
because
because more ceilings have become interesting to
each other, we have even more things to tell each other
from each  meetings, so I
really want this test on the contrary to
know what more And what do you think,
now I can't answer differently,
you may have my own opinion.
to say that
I had no other experience, we have
one wife and I'm happy.
I'm happy that this happened in my life.
One wife, one love, one family, and it's
probably like that again. I'll repeat that all
living people probably have different moments.
in families in different years
I have never felt that there is something wrong
with us something is wrong in our relationship that do
you ever feel sad with me with you or
without you I always liked it very much
and that's why but that's why I don't see big changes
but  what a
war of understanding. It's definitely a
comedic time.
We had a very tight tour
schedule then, and the
guys were constantly traveling. Sometimes I
was with them and other girls too, and when they
saw that we had the
next month more or less Free from
touring and performances, the guys decided that
Well  we need to use it somehow, we were all going to
get married anyway, and I
remember that the three of you, uh, somehow They
told us, listen, we thought here, Let's
do it and everything will be fine, and we
all agreed somehow, on
August 31, our friends had a
wedding  we have a wedding on September 6 and some
friends have a wedding on September 13. Every Saturday we
had
a wedding. This means that I
just didn't have many friends. If there were
10-20 of them, a whole year ago, one person, the
main thing is that there were no
divorces, there were no weekly meetings. This is
the most important thing.  because we hold on, we
definitely hold on, we do
not hold on, no These are the wrong words, did
Ukraine hold on, I
simply could not have done otherwise,
because the President, the leader of the people, the leader of the people,
elected me and the strength of our state is what
I told you about, the strength of our
state, the strength and  the unity of our
people is all together. The government, people, military
people, became military people. People went out from
the very beginning of the war. They went out into the streets
and stopped bare-handed tanks, BMPs, armored personnel carriers, fences,
and did the same thing.
was to
give an opportunity to informationally
introduce chaos on the part of the Russian
Federation to say that
their intimidation worked and informationally
they won and they resisted and the authorities of
Ukraine ran away, I perfectly understood
that what they are counting on
internally is weakness, the weakness of the state, the
weakness of institutions and you can very quickly
occupy one or the other  areas and I will tell you
frankly, unfortunately, it happened in some
small
cities and towns of Ukraine, where Somewhere,
some law enforcement officers ran somewhere, some from the
local authorities, and they went there
faster.
it is impossible
and that is why they held on for a very long time in the east and are
still holding on, that is why I could not
do otherwise, I just did it, I understand it perfectly, I
definitely understood the consequences, the consequences were
more important than what will happen to me tomorrow
Veres
really It was difficult for me I was
a little nervous when I had to  those to the children's rooms
and tell them that the war has started and we
have to somehow now, at least just in case,
collect some things
and fortunately I
had to do this Because when I
went to my daughter's room, for example,
she was already awake And she already understood everything
social networks
work faster than anything in the
world now and luckily I didn't see panic in her eyes.
She just asked what we should
do, I asked my husband that very thing before that,
he told me to wait,
I'll tell you, there were thoughts about whether
we would see each other  again what is it
or not for long how will it develop it
was scary And all this time I didn't have to
show the children that I was confused and
scared I wasn't scared but I had to
constantly keep a cheerful face
talk to him smile
and honestly after
that long day  my cheeks hurt from the fact
that I
was constantly in such a cheerful
state and then, as Volodymyr just
said, for every Ukrainian and for me
too, February 24
is repeated every day, we are in this
February 24, we live, nothing has changed,
some circumstances change, but everything would
we are waiting for only one thing, when it will all be
over. When we can return
to normal life, so
I don't know if
I would wish anyone else in the world to
experience such terrible days as we
experienced at the end of February. I would not
wish this on anyone, but I hope for
100% is better.  We are confident in the future, definitely
lost, definitely peaceful and victorious, I
agree here, absolutely, this is what happened. We
live in such a time,
social networks are faster to explain than
even parents, yes, but I can
say for sure that children, and this applies not
only to our children, but there are many children of this war
You hear what they say, how they
act, what is happening. You
understand that the
war made them grow up and there are many things of
principle that in ordinary life
parents have to explain to their children.
I am proud. I believe with our armed
forces. My son really wants to.
he always supports his wishes. I know he wears a military
uniform. He has a lot of weapons, but they are not the
weapons that our partners give us.
However, he is ready to protect his mother and the
whole family.  for
my family, it is because of the safety as the steps are
very important and when we
could not communicate
and use any means of
communication for a long time, at some point we were able to
have such an
online date and I saw uh children. We
could communicate
and they are proud of me  and it's very
nice to me I can see it I can hear
this one from him
[music]
To be honest I'm already
waiting
I've already answered
similar questions several times and if I
answered every time when our victory
has begun we've already won and I every
time  I can't invent anything else,
because the truth is one. I always knew that
he was the most reliable person, and in these
circumstances, the world simply learned about it in a
wider format, and so did
the children. For the children, he was always a champion, the
best dad and the best person in
their family.  and now they are not
surprised they are calm and confident in
him they support him I am one of
the best families
well one of the many best in our
family many we don't have such a big
family
lucky lucky with friends I think
I'm lucky  an ordinary wife with
my
family without children I think that I am a happy
person absolutely
[music]
and everything is like a service menu
it is not easy when you think about your
family in this example I think only
about my family and that's
how it is  and there are
and these were and are probably goals for
certain people
in the Russian Federation
as far as As for me, I
perceive it as a range as part of
the modern situation in which we
are, we are at war. I
believe that
every person can be a goal and an example  an
example of that is a large number of
rocket artillery and other strikes,
that is,
innocent people suffer,
civilians suffer, military people and I, we, let's
say so, if it is possible to use such a thing.
people
and families are ordinary, but they are also to blame. The only thing is
that they are Ukrainians, it
turns out that way for the Russian
military and Russian politicians, and that's why I
think it's that
I'm nervous.  number two because if you
think about it deeply you can
get paranoid and so I understand that there is the
same mother Like all other mothers and
each of the Ukrainians now they are number two and I
really hate to think that they want to
do something with our family but also  I push
these thoughts away from me, but sometimes when you
see what they did to civilians, they
do to civilians
in all corners of our country that they
were able to reach. You understand that
you don't know what they are, what's in their head
and what's possible, you're really dangerous, but I'm
not  I want to allow these thoughts deep inside me
because it would be really scary and
you can't be afraid of something
[music]
And first of all, the war of Russia against Ukraine on
our land, the United States of America is our partner,
and Russia is the
enemy of the invaders and therefore a partner and  the enemy
cannot agree on the future of our
country, which is choosing its
independence and sovereignty,
nothing will happen without us and it does not matter what
Russia thinks, the important thing is that
our partners, in particular, the
United States of America, in particular, the United States of America, regarding the
statements of the Hungarian Prime Minister, we
sometimes we say something that seems to us, sometimes we
say that we want it to be
like that, but we say, but
the answer is that they are on the ground, and on the ground
we are fighting, and in the sky.
the problem is that
Russia itself
does not understand the consequences of what it
has done, it does not exactly understand the consequences of what
sanctions are because the consequences are already the
introduction of sanctions by the civilized world, this is
already the isolation of the policy of the President of Russia and
their military leadership, this is already a
strong blow to the history of the Russian
Federation in terms of their development and first of all  all the
isolation of their people is to
happen, this is the
second story of the consequences of these sanctions.
relative to Ukraine. This is what he is doing.
I consider him an exception today in the
European Union,
the world was weak in relation to and
very diplomatic. I would say so in
relation to the Russian Federation because the
world in its head and in its
principles has always
divided the leadership of the Russian state and
society and  the world has always said that it is necessary
to show some way out for Russian
society, that we cannot
sanction everyone and because the majority of
people are not to blame for what is
happening and what the Russian
leadership decided regarding the occupation, starting with Crimea
until a full-scale invasion, and then the
world understood No, it cannot be like that  the people, their
society, the Russian Federation, they are
to blame for the fact that they are silent and not
everyone is silent there, there are some voices of Allah, they are
unfortunately lonely, but not all of you, if you give the
opportunity to kill someone, you are not
just witnesses, you are concretely, you are
participants, and therefore you should  do everything
so that your leadership is those whom you elect every 4
or 5 years, and there are already Six.
It seems to me that they changed the Constitution, so it is
your fault, you elect them, which means you
elect a person and put a machine gun
in his hands,
we do not exchange or trade the
territories of an independent  Ukraine We do not
have the right to this, first of all, as the government,
because this land belongs to the people of Ukraine, the
second story. I do not quite understand about
certain compromises or conversations with Russia in the
format in which it was
proposed by the Russian side, and
it was proposed to the ultimatum
format  And ultimatums are not conversations, not
dialogue, and definitely not diplomacy, as
experience has shown that ultimatums with Ukraine do not
work, we have them, you know. Let's put it this way, we are the
descendants of
many
ultimatums from the Russian side
throughout the history of our statehood, and we
know the results. For 3 years, I
offered in Russian  side dialogue
to find a way to a diplomatic solution to the war
and this military conflict before it
was full scale And now believe me
they do not want peace they are not ready for
dialogue what they say in the media and what
they do differ very strongly the
feelings of any civilian in this
wars They are terrible it's uncertainty it's
fear and as you said it's hatred
of the enemy if you explain what
ordinary people feel in war for example to the
average British
try to imagine what will happen tonight
if they hear
sirens and an explosion
near their house what will they be
dealing with for the first time with this  children's room,
where will they run when they
find out that there are already queues to leave the city,
or will they take their favorite
dog or cat with them, such simple, ordinary
human things. They can really
help to understand this
and then imagine that you have stayed and
you  in the occupation and in your cities, on your
street along which the child was taken to school
or kindergarten, a tank drives by, and then
imagine that you have to
make a kind of artificial funeral for your
loved one who died on the
lawn in front of the house because you cannot
do
normal  farewell to a person who died
and then you need to look for water and you
take it from the puddles on the street because there is no
water like in Mariupol, there is no medical
service, there is nothing just you in
your usual room in your
usual circumstances Imagine that in two
hours you will be forced to solve such
things simply  in order to survive and you don't
understand why it happened, it's
unclear how it is possible
to return humanity back to the Middle Ages with just one wrong idea.
I don't know, I really don't have words here. I would
n't even want to
say something out loud because there are
no normal words for this  "
."
first of all, you said that he is
our main enemy in this war,
the most terrible thing is that I think he is
adequate and understands what he is doing.
I think that this is the most terrible conclusion. What can I draw so that
he understands what he is doing? He knows
how much he kills,
he knows how much  and by whom people were raped
and what a large number of children were killed or
deported
and therefore
I understand only one thing that you know the
world gave this opportunity
to grow such a person with such a policy
and with such a meaning and attitude towards
anyone, the world should simply understand
that this is a result and a big  first of
all, the world's mistake is to give opportunities, it's not
about democracy. I don't want to be confused, I
know. Some leaders say that what we should
have done is democracy, it's not about
democracy.
I believe, I'm not the only one who
believes.  it seems to me that they have already
shown the whole world that he can, in
principle, make a
million of his soldiers
die, that is, he can kill us, but it is
impossible to occupy people, but to buy
these villages and cities, but they will all be
destroyed by them, they
cannot capture us without destruction. This is what he can
do
this is task number two As you said there are goals
first goal second goal Russia and there is our goal
Ukraine our goals are our land number
one and number and number one and number two this is
our our land and our people how is it how is it
we need to have it here
aid for today is very important, but
number two is, first of all, the unification of our
people, the strength of the state. Well, it directly
depends on the second reason for aid,
aid, and no matter how it sounds, it's
emergency aid, it's like
9.11 from the whole world right now, powerful
aid to Ukraine
[music  ] there
was such an attitude and such relations between the
leaders because I did not call him through a
bureaucratic line, we spoke with him
maybe once every two days,
daily, then when it was a little easier for us
after the deoccupation of Kyiv, we spoke with him every week
and spoke more than once a month
or every six months  this suggests that we
ourselves at the level of leaders resolved the issue,
that is why we were so close, she was with him,
she was. By the way, and with
some other partnerships.
Yes, I am worried about this. This does not mean that the
policy of Great Britain will change, no. I
know that anyone, who would  I was not one of these
respectable candidates for leadership positions in Great
Britain. Whoever will be the
prime minister in the future, they
will help Ukraine and
will be just like Boris, but I am worried, you
asked me. I am very worried. We want it to
be at least on the same level
because our personal relationship, I think,
influenced the speed of aid to
Britain and their leadership positions in this
aid
All be back The [
music]
I think that I have no right to
play politics inside
Great Britain, I can only say that
he is a great friend of Ukraine and of course  I would
very much like him to be in one or another
place, it depends on the people of
Great Britain, but I would very much like
him
not to disappear anywhere and I am sure that this
will be the case, whatever the political position
or position of Boris Johnson, he
will always be  with Ukraine, because it is from the heart, and on this
topic,
what can I say, I will be
happy to work in such an artificial
contact.
As we had fundraisers in the same
close contact between Ukraine and
Great Britain, I know that these are two respectable
persons and Great Britain is a people first  the whole
society supports them, we know
the details of this support and the positive
strengths of these leaders, we will work
with whoever is chosen,
I know better Ms. Lee Straz, we had the
opportunity to somehow have contacts, I am
sure
in any case, whoever will be the
future leader with  of these two respected
personnel. I am sure that the support of
Ukraine will be at a high level.
I think that this is a great signal, a great
signal, everyone can see how Ukraine treats the
United States, the highest support is
very high and there was great support from the
first lady, who met with
salt here, it was right for us
The visit was
very Let's say so unexpected, we were expecting it
but it was unexpected, it happened, these are important
things, then Elena's trip will
not speak for itself, I can say that this is a very
important moment and she did a great
job and her work worked, there are quick
decisions of the Congress and the White House that
appeared  After the
deer's speech and visit,
these are very important things, and the arrival of
President Biden in Ukraine is
the most powerful signal that can be of
support for Ukraine. We are waiting, I
can tell you that the help will not be
enough until the war is over and
until we are victorious.  I
spoke with President Biden several times,
I told him, well, you know, I
have to fight for our people, for
my people and the country, so I'm sorry if I'm
sometimes firm in my positions and
say some things that aren't very diplomatic, and
he very decently answered me that I
understand  in your place, I would have done the
same
so many times already in my
presidential life.
in NATO I believe that
I am not sure that the current President of Russia would be the
current President of Russia for them,
this is the greatest weakness and the greatest
victory of the Western world,
this is the first, the second, I believe that
NATO will be involved and already diplomatically
involved because
Russia, you will hear their messages, they
speak against  with the name and NATO why Because
Russia will never be able to live with the fact that
Ukraine is a country that is 28 times smaller
than the great Russian army and the State that
it is fighting for its
freedom And nothing has happened for 3-5 days for the
occupation with this program
How should they communicate with
their society, they say it's not
Ukraine, the fighter is with us, NATO is fighting with us, that's why it is one way
or another, but we understand
that the main enemy for Russia is NATO, and that's
why
I think there's nothing to be afraid of. There's nothing to be
afraid of. Ukraine deserves  to
be in NATO with one's strength and
strength. I believe that these would be the best
guarantees of security, but until NATO does not
see us, or let's say that not all
NATO countries see us in the alliance. For thousands of
reasons, it does not matter that they do not see us, that's
why we need guarantees now  of security
and that's where I count most
of all on
Britain and the United States that they
will be the engine of the process and we will be able to
get security guarantees
from America.
We are fighting for absolutely common and equally understood values.
and the war in Ukraine is still a war
against those values ​​that the
United States of America and Europe profess, there
is no distance, today the salvo rockets
fly for more than several thousand
kilometers, and tomorrow they will have other
missiles that will fly for 10,000 km,
what is the difference between them  to kill civilians who do
not agree with the policy of the
President of Russia, what difference does it make to them, so this
war here is security for us and
I'm sorry to say so cynically, but this is security
today for Europe while we stand and
will stand the state of the United
States and there will be security So we
give  your life for your values ​​and
for common security in the world and therefore
inflation is nothing covid is nothing You ask
our people who lost their children at the beginning of a
full-scale invasion
peace housing who is thinking about masks or
prokovits who is thinking about inflation these are
secondary reasons the most important thing is  to
survive and preserve the life of one's family, one's
country, and therefore, while we are doing this, and the
west should help us
[music]
for weight, we hear headlights from Putin's gas
skiers,
if he wants to use it, it will not be
related to what it can be  connected
only with his decision with their ambitious
plans listen otherwise And what And
if tomorrow he says you know that
Germany I think
half of Germany was there Germany was
divided after the Second World War I
think that half is ours I
think so  that we must have influence there and
our troops will be there, otherwise
I will use nuclear weapons, so why should
everyone raise their hands and
surrender? This is definitely not the choice of the Ukrainian
people, and I believe that it is not the choice of Europe and the
United States. Therefore, there is no need to think
about  that he will use nuclear weapons
again, I said this from the very beginning.
I don't know what his goals are and what the
civilized world will allow him to do. He will show
weakness. He will use everything. I will
show strength.
sout
it's even unpleasant, I don't pay attention to it
when the words are empty,
something is very populist in their society,
I don't
pay attention to it.
we
were made, and secondly, I would look at the
biography of the relatives and friends of
President Putin, what happened to them during the years of
Nazism and the years of the Second World War, where
were they, what happened and who did he
lose, and I looked at my
natives, who are they, what is their blood, where are they
all  and why I don't have a
big family living family Why were they
tortured by the Nazis and what happened to
his relatives whether they were in occupation or
not What happened I would pay
attention to this not only in this question I
think that political leaders
political leaders  of the Russian Federation, I
would not address their families for a long time, this is very
important, the truth.
I think that
you know, any war
definitely ends with diplomacy. I
think that for today, my impression is that the
result of this diplomacy will be a
conversation between the Ukrainian side,
in the presence of our partners, for sure, and
the Russian side  side, and for today it
seems to me the only possible model to
talk to someone else, not even the current
leader of the Russian Federation,
this is the reality of the
reality we live in. Well, I will tell you
honestly, I am
proud of the fact that
honestly this happened, I am proud of the fact that I am the
President of Ukraine, that the people elected me,
this is real  And what is realism? It seems to me that it is
more about what is happening with
our neighbors, what with those with whom we
lived for many, many years, they decided to
attack us and kill us, this is the majority of
realism, for sure
[music]
several hours of difficult negotiations and he  I
probably thought every day Now I
have to somehow sit down to talk and something was
postponed postponed postponed
until I saw
her New Year's address on TV about the fact that he is
on New Year's Eve
[laughter] [
music]
Please say this question
[music]
And I don't  I wanted to ask very meticulously.
Well, let's tell me at the end
or not. I thought that the time would come when
he would say, but I didn't think that it would be at
this moment.
Look, wait, first of all, everyone was talking about it.
we all talked about it in
society, many things. I didn't make an
official statement. Let's just say that it was uh.
Look, it was a difficult decision for
our family. I knew that it would be
a blow for them and I know that it is a difficult challenge.  it is a
difficult challenge and it is not to be swallowed, it is a very
serious matter and we did not sit down to talk about it,
it is true we did not sit down to
talk about it for a long time And separately I spoke
separately Elena spoke and we could not I
think that
the moment is such, you understand the moment What about it
frankly  Everyone delayed talking
because my family wasn't ready to let me
go and it's absolutely true. Second,
when I'm informational, I'm the first time to
be a candidate. Yes, and yes, Olena Olena
heard Olena heard there is one.
decision
[laughter]
I can become president
I can say I'm glad they admit they were
wrong I
feel that way I see a lot of support I
know what people are telling me
Please convey to the president What We believe in
him and me besides the fact that I'm his wife I  I am
also a citizen of Ukraine and I
like this president. It
seems to me that people love every
Ukrainian. He is really
one of the last heroes of the nation.
arsenal, we will
all become fans of Arsenal, it is
possible that
Victoria Zinchenko was invented by me, I
am honest. Well, we are all fans of Zinchenko, as
Olena said. I personally know many of
our beautiful football players, and I will honestly
tell you that they do a great job,
great work. They are famous people and they are
very  they help Shevchenko, he's very cool, I
can't say that I love Shevchenko out of others,
because Shevchenko won't
talk to me later,
and on the contrary, I don't want to talk about them, there are really
a lot of them. Believe me, there are those who are legends and
they took automatons, they don't play now,
they took automatons  and went to the fronts and
we know from Dynamo Kyiv and so I
mean that
I am a football fan as it seems to me I was like
that with you before" [
music]
Glory to Ukraine
...
[music]